the summit may look magical but the foot
of the mountain also has plenty to offer
it's a really beautiful autumn day the
trees are slowly turning yellow a great
time for walking mountain guide hunts
Atal is taking the beneden snake path
the two walkers are completely alone
here
wonderful rock pinnacle here amazing
what nature creates quite take 25
minutes sukshm it's a peak nine hours
won't make that today
that's the summit of the student that's
where we're going it takes two and a
half hours to get from Crytek to the top
of the Steuben mountain the route passes
the foot of the Alpen spits a mountain
through the Bernardin valley and from
there it's straight up the silver
thistle is a clear sign of autumn higher
up parts of the mountains are already
under snow on the right is the arch
bitter mountain on the left the
hopelessness the hope Lawson
one thought the path up the tool Pizza
is already tricky there's lots of snow
is it just dog which need be hold it but
no problems here oh yeah further down
and on the south side it's better
especially with today's wonderful
weather gentian Lila for Bernie helps
tension the last few minutes up to the
summit of the Steuben are steeper but
they finally make it made it to the top
wonderful
I cannot aim for having reached their
goal the two walkers can sit and enjoy
the mountain panorama
the other health autumn in the mountains
is just a dream everything comes
together to make it a wonderful time
just look down there it's gorgeous but I
own off with a cold wind already blowing
they start for home you always have to
watch the time in autumn says hon settle
because the days get shorter in the
mountains too